welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boston this is a breakdown of the
Mandalorian season 3 episode 6 chapter
22 guns for hire a clone wars throwback
vibe that ends with Dooku love and Doc
Brown getting shocked
from Tom Holland's brother as a mon
calamari Romeo to oribesh in mandoa
translations and hidden sound effects I
got you covered with the scene by scene
breakdown of all the Star Wars Easter
eggs you missed we opened with a quorin
freighter now quarans are the amphibious
species who share the planet moncala
with them on calamari and mon calamari
Cruisers like home one that was Admiral
akbar's Flagship in return the Jedi were
constructed from aquatic cities on the
planet of moncala so presumably this
fighter could also go underwater thus
its submarine looking design in its
curved hole I also just like that they
have the same color and thin shape of
the Corn head it'd be like us piloting
space with ships that look like our
heads Cory zamon Calamari have
historically been at war with each other
and in the first three episodes of Clone
Wars season 4 we got to see a lot of
that where the chords were backed by
separatists but the mon calamari were
able to reject the separatist influence
and reach a piece on the planet now
these chords are bypassing trade routes
to the planet Trask that was a
water-covered planet that we saw in
chapter 11 the last episode of the
Mandalorian directed by Bryce Dallas
Howard she also directed in one of the
best episodes of The Book of Boba Fett
we meet Captain sugath who's played by
Christine Adams from Black Lightning and
she has a cocktail that is poured into
her tank for her to eat that little
fishy I might be the only person who
notices this but when she eats the fish
the water swish sound effect is from the
same audio asset Library as Crash
Bandicoot warped when crash spins in the
underwater levels
foreign
get to be in a water tank while the
other corn have to be in open air I just
like to think it's a cool ceremonial
thing for court and captains to be more
in tune with their home Waters we find
out she's in love with this mon calamari
Prince played by Harry Holland that's
Tom Holland's brother fun little trivia
Point here Christine Adams is 48. Harry
Holland is 24. nice moth Gideon's
Imperial light Cruiser fills the frame a
recurring Star Wars visuals since the
first shot of A New Hope but this tells
us that after the events of the season 2
finale Gideon's ship was left with
bogoton's group including the ex-wooves
and remember X wolves was in bogoton's
group when we first met them in live
action on Trask and he's joined here by
Costco Reeves now sugath has to break up
with her boyfriend and they share this
romantic kiss her tentacles caressing
his face it's so sweet and so romantic
also it's nice to see one quaran on the
show who isn't a total bocaton
didn't jar and grogu and R5 take the
gauntlet to plazier 15. with a glass
Dome City structures like what the
mandalorians had on Mandalore now the
word Placer means peaceful and with its
dome in monorail Epcot definitely seems
to be an inspiration here I like how the
gauntlet cuts through the clouds with
the same framing as it did over sundari
in chapter 18 which is what I hope
happens to this planet their ship is
commandeered by Pleasure 15 Mission
Control
[Music]
welcome to pleasure 15 the outer rims
only remaining direct democracy so by
direct democracy they're referring to a
political system where instead of a
republic where the masses elect
representatives to make decisions for
them all decisions are instead made by
popular vote like how in the United
States some states will let residents
vote on a wide range of ballot measures
like should we build a bridge put into a
vote should we renew sales taxes put
that into a vote as opposed to and just
vote where city council or Governor
Senate and they'll represent your
interests plus year 15 makes the case
that separatist-aira direct democracy is
at least worth trying since the Republic
and the new Republic now and the
military dictatorship of the empire in
between have all failed people I like
our Pokemon screen reads the mandoa
language control override they're
greeted by a black-plated ra7 protocol
Droid an astronomic Droid typically seen
on Imperial ships now the hyperlink
monorail pod voice cites article 9 of
the Coruscant Accords which was also
cited in chapter 19 in reference to the
prohibition on cloning research these
were signed at the end of the Galactic
Civil War before the new Republic
Capital was moved to chandrilla but this
voice is actually a cameo by Catherine
Tabor the voice of Padme in Clone Wars
baby Gresham only scan their chain codes
these orange tinted Holograms of mandoah
text from their gauntlets like what Boba
Fett showed in chapter 14 to prove his
Mandalorian ancestry from his clone
father Django and his teacher of Jesse
Mariel inside the palace guards are
wearing repurposed stormtrooper armor
and we see some colorful fauna flapping
around overhead in this kind of Atrium
space there's a tank above their heads
with an aquatic creature they could get
a much better look at in the closing
credits concept art it's from this tank
that they are all taking little sippy
sips through these hoses I think that's
a little Nuna that jumps on the table
there and sitting at this table is an
assortment of rhodians bits eitherians
celestins that frog-like Grace of the
lady in chapters 10 11 and at the head
of the table Captain Bombardier and The
Duchess played by Jack Black and lizzo
and look I get it these cameos did make
this feel like a bit of an SNL sketch or
remember when Jack Black and Cloris
Leachman came out in that in Universe
movie in the Super Bowl episode of The
Office hey kudos to Jack Black and lizzo
for committing to the bits and not like
winking at the camera or anything but
they're just Larger than Life presences
and casting them and not disguising them
under alien makeup just took me out of
it a bit I think Star Wars can pull off
this casting in small doses like Tim
Meadows or Thundercat in the book of
Boba Fett or the comedic character
actors who really commit to the dirty
scamps who definitely fit in this world
like Amy cedarius's palimoto Bill Burrus
makes mayfeld when Stephen and fruit
played that water hoarder in the book of
Boba Fett and I don't think I would feel
this way if it was just lizzo or just
Jack Black but these two huge stars
together was just kind of Overkill like
a little example of this listen closely
to what Jack Black is singing in the
scene
he's singing the song Do You Love Me
from Fiddler on the Roof it's a show
tune and it's in Star Wars what but
musically I do like that we hear this
flute music when they walk in
[Music]
join us come
I'm pretty sure this is the flute music
of lizzo herself because she is so good
at that flute I guess the only way I can
defend this casting is maybe as a meta
indictment on The Perils of direct
democracy like Bombardier says they're
both Royals and elected leaders meaning
the citizens of plazier 15 elected pop
culture celebrity dimwits as their
leaders kind of liking Mike judge's
excellent film idiocracy but I'm not
convinced this episode proved they
intended this to be satirical political
commentary I just think felony and vavro
wanted some goofy Clone Wars filler
episode hijinks with some fun cameos I
mean whatever I've gone on this for too
long I do really like the way Jack Black
pronounces the word program and thanks
to the new Republic amnesty program I
personally oversaw the program
Bombardier refers to the bantha in the
room which is ironic because they used
an elephant named Margie to play the
bantha in A New Hope and notice how he
has an amnesty orbash a badge like Elia
Kane and Dr Pershing had this serves as
a literal scarlet letter that they must
wear to show their past crimes The
Duchess seat has a hologram feathery
plumage that follows her around making
it a kind of Throne or a crown for
wherever she happens to be sitting as
the touches wherever she is sitting is
the de pecto Throne they tasked bocaton
and didn't jaran with investigating some
Droid malfunctions using the fact that
as mandalorians they could carry their
weapons inside the city promising to
legally recognize Mandalore to the new
Republic but for dinner and his
interests are more simple than that you
had me at battle droids now what I'm
struggling to get about this is that
part of din Jordan's character
development over these past seasons has
been a gradual forgiveness of droids
like he definitely hated him in the
pilot coming from his traumatic
childhood when B2 series battle droids
killed his parents but the First
episodes of this season showed him going
to Great Lengths to revive ig-11 someone
he considered a friend so why does he
suddenly now hate droids again they meet
security commissioner Hellgate played by
Christopher Lloyd he says the droids
were planned to be scrapped to carthan
those are the chatfields where they
found migs Mayfield in chapter 15. and
from here the episode becomes a mystery
detective procedural like iRobot for an
episode of Law and Order that includes
casting a semi-big name as someone the
detective's interview early on who
inevitably ends up being the bad guy the
orbital security screen reads camera
703-739 and above that sectors 7g which
is where Homer Simpson Works in The
Simpsons we see a sanitation Droid who
tosses garbage everywhere like a
sanitation worker who's just really
having a rough day we see a battle droid
who throws clothes around and a valet
Droid who hijacks this meter and runs it
directly into the wall all of these very
much first world problems I love it
there's a CEO series cook Droid though
like we saw Navarro in chapter 17 and in
Jabba's Palace the book of Boba Fett and
a cutaway but it sounds like he chops
those people to death and in this room
the orbash sigil on the back wall reads
plazier 15 you know the the name of the
planet kind of like how in our buildings
we have uh walls that say Earth Hellgate
says that the citizens voted to have no
interruption to Droid services that they
cannot live without it much like the
future humans of Pixar's Wally he says
that they spend all their time with the
Arts and voting on a bunch of stuff
which is what happens into direct
democracy you wouldn't have time to do
anything else other than to vote and I
guess to take a bunch of improv classes
I'm a big fan of being my best self and
Beyond failing my brain with fun things
to think about dogs wearing pants
hamsters and top hats you know the usual
stuff I also like to take care of my
body and if you like taking care of your
body You're Gonna Want to fully tune in
because we are going to have one of the
best offers we've ever given on this
channel thanks to geology geology is an
18-time award-winning skin hair and body
care company recognized in men's health
Oprah daily hypebeast birdie Esquire and
GQ geology creates simple and effective
skin care and Hair Care routines
customized just for you with ingredients
that are proven to work their products
are built around just a handful of
powerful proven ingredients that have
been trusted by dermatologists for
decades just take a quick 30 second
diagnostic quiz and geology will create
a simple and effective skincare or hair
care routine customized just for you
with ingredients that are dermatologist
tested proven to work and personalized
to your needs geology has got you
covered no matter how you're looking to
up your personal care game but right now
they are offering a special offer for a
skincare sampler pack which is great
because their skincare stuff rules
geology's line of skincare products can
help you fight acne reduce oilness
prevent wrinkles and combat dark or
puffy under eyes have smoother hydrated
skin and Target signs of aging
personally I'm a fan of their vitamin C
plus e fioric acid serum but I use
everything else geology has co-wash for
your hair body wash for your body and
deodorant for your odors whatever you
need jelly has to cover there's never
been a better time to try geology than
right now for a limited time to use code
new Rockstar's 100 to get 100 off your
personalized 30 day skincare sample set
all you have to do is cover the 495 for
shipping this is hands down the best
deal that is out there and on top of
that new Rockstar's fans get an
exclusive bonus offer up to 50 off on
additional skin hair and body product of
your choice when you add it to your
trial click the link in the description
or go to
geolog.i.e rockstars 100 to get started
in the ugnots Droid shop we see parts of
B2 battle droids B1 battle droids
protocol droids and Ralph McCoy's
original protocol Droid Design but this
season has brought back a few times like
that taxi Droid and Coruscant Boca time
insults them by saying their machines
are malfunctioning and that they may not
have heard much down here but the dog
not says that the tunnels are really the
central nervous system of the city
something Mando can relate with as a
former sewer dweller and I like this
this is my favorite scene of the episode
because it demonstrates that dengarn has
changed over the course of the series
that he's been affected by his past
relationship with kuil and it's now
given him a diplomatic tactic that
bogoton lacks Mando kicks a marching B2
like the Boston Dynamics Engineers who
kicked that robot dog a terrible idea
because you know they'll never forget
that this is also like an iRobot when
Will Smith Goes robot by robot shooting
some threatening them until he outs a
malfunctioning Rogue leading to this
amazing Chase through the streets now
the B1 series Droid Foreman is a voice
by Matthew Wood long time lucasfilm's
sound editor who voiced General Grievous
bit Fortuna and all the Animated Series
battle droids he always does such great
work but I think my favorite thing that
he ever said was
now there are some interesting contrasts
here between dinjar and bogoton during
this Chase like din jumps over the
barrels with his own strength bogoton
uses her jet thrusters and when that B2
Droid throws a crate bogoton uses her
thrusters to blast ahead to keep moving
whereas din turns around to make sure no
one was hurt and yes they passed a ton
of neon orabesh signs there's yellow in
Reading Joanna Cafe a white one reading
open right before that there was a mouse
droid screwing around there are some
vertical pink signs reading the orbit in
nightclub next to it I'd like to hit
that place for a drink now as the crate
flies over their heads over on the left
side of screen there's a Droid Shop with
a pink sign reading premium Droid
rentals there's some other signs for
bars or clubs called Hades dog and
apocalypse right beneath that flickering
in for coming again I hope this is for
shadowing the apocalyptic Doom of this
planet especially since after this
episode it no longer has hired guns to
defend it the speeder that the B2 jumps
on looks like one with the body of the
speed that Han drives on corellia and
solo a Star Wars story but has the grill
of Luke Skywalker speeder in a new hope
they run past four speeder bikes all
white which might be a meta nod to the m
m colored versions of these bikes that
people complained about in The Book of
Boba Fett same bikes just without the
distracting colors there's a yellow sign
reading spa and another yellow road sign
it looks like warning about speed so Dan
ends the chase by tackling the B2
through a window and Pokemon disables
his shoulders from behind a few
Constable droids roll out
yeah those Sirens are the same siren
sound effects from Minority reports
their Hollow police tape reads caution
in orabesh and in another language and
reflected on the ground from the blue
neon sign above is orabesh 4 Dive Bar as
they walk down the street another
orabesh bar sign reads flaming lizard
there's some spinning text overhead in
the Hologram including the word quality
that's in blue and beneath in purple
gravity scooters I really think plugging
those white scooters that we saw before
and then they turn down the alley to the
resistor bar and blew across the street
behind them I think that says
Refreshments then there are two of those
Macquarie protocol droids hitting on
each other in the alley and they enter
the resistor bar inside I love this gag
with several flasks clinting but they're
all being carried by the multiple hands
of one suo series cook Droid our man is
like quadruple fisting can't blame them
they've seen a lot we see an antennaeed
Rickshaw Droid that we saw at the end of
book of Boba Fett some RX series droids
like you know Rex from Star Tours he's
also in the bar and Galaxy's Edge
they're playing a card game of sabak we
see a bunch of protocol droids Astromech
droids EV series droids our A7 droids B1
battle droids but the bartender is
voiced by Seth Gable the actor from
Fringe Salem and nipped he says his
droid's fear replacement which is what
happened to these Droids when the
separatists were defeated by the
Republic Empire by this point they were
defeated by the Clone Trooper Army but
then these clone troopers were replaced
by human recruits the bartender says
they all dream I'll drink Nepenthe which
is a viscous lubricant that protects
from where and delivers refreshing
subparticles now the word empathy comes
from a forgetfulness drug in Greek
mythology translating to that which
chases away sorrow making this a really
sad drink for these poor droids and the
horrors they've witnessed we learned
that all the malfunctioning droids drank
from the same batch of it a bad batch
she might say and they go to a Droid
morgue this lab tech is played by Jen
cover who showed up in the righteous
gemstones she uses a white medical probe
Droid to extract the Nepenthe Dr
Pershing used one of these on grogu in
chapter 3 and Darth Vader used one of
these on Leia in A New Hope as with the
B2 Droid earlier this one's light turns
red reminding us of Hal in 2001 A Space
Odyssey and Otto in Wali all these May
link back to that red button on
hellgate's desk which he later reveals
is actually a Fail-Safe switch to turn
all of the droids hostile he actually
may be activating each of these Droids
every time DIN and Beau get closer and
closer to finding the truth but then
brings this one down with the dark saber
so they continue analyzing the
sub-particles and the text says that
they were made by the Techno Union this
was part of the separatists in the
prequels it was one of the just looked
like a big dumb robot who sat at the
table these represent a group of tech
corporations who were eventually taken
over by the Empire they actually see
their Guild sigil showing up in the
corner when we see that ID screen of
Hellgate later there's a lot of orabesh
on this screen first on the right column
that or best translates to scope active
zoom level and controls and then they
realize that each of the Nanobots has
more writing on it a chain code that is
revealed on a green screen with a ton of
orabesh text and since we're seeing from
behind we gotta reverse it or you can
just look at it from the text point of
view the big words translate to code
deciphering Search complete but then you
see words like command denav and the
words at this point just start to be
gibberish I'm pretty sure I translate as
much as I could and then I just lost my
mind because it's all just like random
letters but the final ID screen for
Hellgate is an amazing troll from the
bfx artist for us nerds it translates to
this means nothing however fans May and
it's not however with a p I think they
might have been a mistake this is
however fans May interpret the hell out
of it CSI FTW for the win I love it
thank you for throwing that in there for
us so when they confront commissioner
Hellgate he asks himself as a dogmatic
separatist and Dooku supporter and
Christopher Lloyd is so good at this
he's one of the best actors to reveal
himself as a villain famously as judge
doom and Who Framed Roger Rabbit
s okay rants
he was consorted in his prime by that
Jedi of horses
focus on cut him off right as he was
about to say cut in short in his brine
by the Jedi enforcer Anakin Skywalker
and mixed into that zap I'm pretty sure
it's a bit of the singe sound effect we
heard when Anakin cut Dooku short do we
go
and Christopher Lloyd sells this so well
he's also one of the best actors to just
play electrocution between Doc Brown and
Uncle Fester so the Dutchess and her
husband are playing a croquet type game
with these things that roll up reminds
me of Alice in Wonderland when the Queen
of Hearts plays croquet and grow who
uses the force to help her cheat but
martier calls Hellgate despicable and he
responds if that is
calling the stiff thing slimy which is
something we heard in the season 2
finale when Boba Fett said this to
Costco Reeves
slimy and in the book of boba Fest from
CAD Bean if that's not the quack to call
in the stifling slimy The Duchess Exiles
Hellgate to the Moon of paraquat and in
this court a Droid carries a tray with a
key to the city this is the Same Led
series service Droid that was chased
around Java's Palace in the book of
buffet now the game of the city actually
kind of looks
about that but looks like something
specific and then she Knights grogu I
guess for helping her cheat you are now
a knight of the Ancient Order of
independent regions yeah that French
horn theme is the grogu music that
played when Mando and grogu were United
so they head out to the Mandalorian camp
where they find ax wolves he has some
banners in mandoa that my buddy Ryan
area from screen Crush says translate to
besla not so sure about that though
because it looks like a lot more than
six letters house diesela wouldn't be
represented here there with the children
of the watch it looked like 13 letters I
was thinking maybe night owls maybe this
is the way but honestly I translated it
upside down backwards forwards it just
looks like gibberish I think but cool
Easter egg here in this yard is that
ship that they stole from Trask in
chapter 11. they keep everything they
take so bogoton ends up defeating ax
wolves in a duel but he still discounts
didn't jarin as an impure family not a
drop of Mandalorian blood in him which
makes X wolves a bit of a racist so to
win over the skept dates ninjarin uses
some Elder Wand logic about
what happened in the minds Mandalore and
how pokotan slayed his captor who had
disarmed him of the dark saber and you
know what it works on everybody but I
love this final shot focus on ignites
the dark saber but unlike the moment in
Rebels when she held it over her head
here she keeps it lower at her side as
if to show she has now learned the
weight of the responsibility of wielding
this blade a reminder to subscribe to
our new channel the Deep dive and you
can support our Channel by grabbing some
merch at nerd riot.shop you can follow
me on Instagram and Twitter at eavos
follow new rockstars And subscribe to
new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]